welcome back to sims 4 we're gonna play
a game and we're going to have some fun
okay so what I want to do is I want to I
want to own an experiment with a type of
playing this game that I've never really
played before first of all we're not
making the appliers we already did that
what kind of what kind of what kind of
crazy person do you think I am that I'm
just gonna be remaking the employers no
that's stupid you're stupid I'm not
stupid
I'm gonna be making some original
characters because everyone's always
clamoring look dude dude dark dude do
the Google know it's stupid you're
stupid and I'm not stupid any
suggestions will get you an instant ban
maybe maybe so everybody shut up let me
deal with this we're gonna call you
we're gonna call you sping go we're good
we're gonna call you spring go is that
snow sping go bingo bingo all right what
do we got it oops
okay all right whoops oops
can I make the arms can I make the arms
longer in any way is that even remotely
possible about this tell me about it can
I make your shoulders whoa whoa all
right that's good there uh-huh I don't
like it I don't love it actually I don't
like it at all
how do I do the face again I've
completely forgotten how to do anything
in this game I've got all this hair
[ __ ] here oh that that's not what
the picture looked like that's good
enough I call this the may I please
speak to your manager look detail edit
mode that's what I was looking for okay
this gone these sultry this curious but
only one of them can only one of them be
care ok very surprised
flared pinched drooped smooched
unplumbed very plumped chin chiseled but
lumpy there we go ears real nothing
apparently you can't edit ears ears are
the Forbidden Zone
as is obvious to everybody ears are
absolutely forbidden
okay how about mouth back that's good
face forward chin out gullet up
oh no there we go like there we go from
that's what I'm talking about
all right nose well yep no let's not be
comical about this that's good they're
bridge up let's try to take this a
little bit serious Lee's eyes sunken all
right looks good from the front oh yeah
from the front pretty good from the side
mmm not not as not as good bingo here uh
bingo here
oof there is no way to edit the ears
okay it's it's a goddamn mystery your
ears are just an enigma and they don't
work half the time that's fine basically
your entire face is trying to escape
your skull I've even I think I think I
feel a problem Oh even better even
better okay you know what I'm gonna get
out of here and I'm gonna see what a
different hairstyle looks like Oh
[Music]
Grune Hilda all right so there's sping
go a Brunhilde ha ha let's see what else
we can do to ruin this oh no no no shits
god [ __ ] damn it back ok perfect
all right it's fine everything's fine
everything's still here we go all right
this bingo Brunhilde we call her spinny
cuz whoo - oh god with the shoulders all
right Strunk unstruck broad-shouldered
but unstrung rotund
non rotund Oh neck thick as always need
to hold up that head somehow can we get
a little bit of spine a bit low
ah all right hunch that's good what
about the lower lumbar nope hmm
nope hmm nope tokus out there all right
knees naba Lee ash
you can't do the knees I was trying to
make you a hideously deformed but
somehow I'm even more attracted to you
you're a goddamn delight now let's see
all these goddamn outfits that I paid
money for perfect alright nothing else
perfect that's your date hmm what did I
pay money for perfect I love it
boots already perfect but let's see if
we can improve on perfect bad or even
better
got it oh oh no I don't like that I can
see your spinal column so much though at
least she's happy okay all right well
this is spangled Brunhilde she really
really would DV annum huh she wants to
be a furry is that what that is is that
what that supposed to be is this
supposed to be oh just a friend of the
animals okay not definitely not a furry
but you know you never know could be no
not saying it's a furry but could be you
are goddamn self confident no stop that
you know brynhilda please stop that
actually I'm gonna rename this is the
first name is gonna be Brunhilde because
that's obviously a first name and
there's gonna be this bingo
the Shingo family very cheerful happy is
good
all right so very happy very very happy
squeamish
why are you still smiling she can't not
smile clumsy that's cuz she's so
top-heavy she literally cannot keep
balanced her tiny waist is never gonna
be able to keep track a goof okay
self-assured cheerful goofball all right
so this is Brunhilde yeah
add a cult sim what is it a cult sim huh
hey Lynn the alien oh I'm gonna go back
to Brunhilde for a second here cuz I
didn't get the voice all right what walk
style oh my god it's oh my god oh my god
alright yeah okay we're done all right
this is sphingo this one's this we'll
figure out the name the name comes later
when you get to person at whoa oh can
this sim use the toilet that's
fascinating custom gender settings ah
forward-thinking I'm not gonna mess with
that but now forward thinking of you you
[Laughter]
goddamn snooty all right
bingo all right okay I like what we've
got going nope
and that's hangout lit we got a really
all right first off let's get some
things right right off the bat okay
that's that's just the first step
all right let's fix you you are just so
okay you are just okay you you can't be
ripped or unrep tat all hmm okay
all right let's get the details of the
face no one will ever be able to
expect that you're an alien yep that's
what I wanted
yep that's all so yup yup yup yup yup
okay we've got that this there we go in
in tuck it in tuck tuck
talk tuck it in talk it out tuck him
back there we go okay so far so terrible
talk Oh rosy cheeks okay hang on oh I've
ruined everything okay
oh no okay tuck that up I gotta get rid
of this beard sorry but you don't seem
like the type to have a beard hides up
here this is the better beard this this
this this this this this this perfect
got it
no okay I keep white well I'm grabbing
on the lips why did you change the face
then huh what just change the whole
goddamn head if you just were gonna be
very grumbled to tuck that bottom chin
lip up plump the top lip out there we go
tuck that up in there we go
no no no no one would ever know that
you're an alien no one could possibly
ever know that you're an alien no one's
gonna know how would anyone know they'd
be an idiot if they knew they'd be
stupid if they knew why would they know
bottom chin not the top would hey shut
up shut up okay what about the alien
part can you fix that at all
can I fix this do I want to fix this
what's with your eyes ah oh what's wrong
with your eyes close those off No close
those off no one wants to see those Oh
gross close those off get those out of
here
make it as in and up as possible tiny
eyes the tinier the better
I literally how do I get tinier give me
tiny there we go tiny no one wants to
see those get those up get those in
there
tiny never show those ever again never
ever show your eyes to anybody ever
let's just get all the other features on
your face to be a distraction from the
horror that's within your eyes Oh No
very sad alien my
years whoa okay let's see even those are
sad lose the cheeks sad forehead sack
lips add bottom chin very sad all right
well that's the saddest you could
possibly get I've got I couldn't get you
any sadder because this one's mope oh
this one mobile mope oh that's mofo
finger he's so goddamn sad oh well this
looks marginally not as sad but let's
fix that we didn't we didn't want to
give any an inkling that there could
possibly be any happy there we go wait a
little more a little more you can go
more oh oh no oh so we got mobo bingo
here
let's make mobile how do I can i oh I
have to do it in alien mode okay
aspiration um you just want love that's
all you want you want to find the one
you're here on earth because you were so
hideously ugly in your home planet that
nobody could possibly love you okay your
gloomy is so sad
a dance machine Insider that's awful
oh it's terrible you're the saddest
gloomiest insider that who ever was
okay so here's how this gonna go once
upon a time long long ago Brunhilde here
was stomping through the woods so so
creepily like you know she was doing her
normal midnight to 3:00 a.m. walk
through the woods to maintain her
incredible physique and and never look
at her anywhere but straight up
alright so she was going through the
woods at night and then mo PO came down
after being evicted from his home planet
for being so horrendously hideously ugly
that everyone just thought that
Brunhilde was hopeless but then mo PO
met and then they fell in love
nope they they fell in love and now they
are
Ben den wife isn't that a beautiful
story okay so if I'm not mistaken if I'm
not mistaken
isn't there an option sim lifespan short
there we go
I'm gonna make them have very very short
lifespans so they have to they have to
breed as fast as they can to try to
procreate they both don't have a lot of
time left in fact they really don't have
a lot of time left they are they are in
there they're they they don't got time
so they gotta make babies and they gotta
make them fast we got to make babies and
lots of them in fact if we can do custom
gender settings let's make this sim can
become pregnant and wait no get others
pregnant is it okay is there no can't
you do is there no both oh how
progressive are you really
well can't do both I would you get
pregnant you you you get brutal don't
turn your head just a word of advice
Brunhilde you can get pregnant the other
one will get you pregnant makes sense
we're gonna make some babies okay the
spring go household Oh a match made in
hell oh my god I match though all right
here we go let's see what happens
select a season to play with no season
of love winter
perfect perfect time to snuggle up in
the cold and make some babies we're
better to make babies the desert no wind
didn't berg I don't know where that is
San mushi what forgotten Hall a perfect
in the haunted area there's no one here
perfect no one to judge us how much
money do we have I can't afford dick we
got a build one Flender Moss Bend get us
in there okay we got to get utilitarian
right okay so the only objective here is
to make literally as many babies as we
can we don't have a lot of time you are
just delightful where is the house we're
what's our lot I don't know what our lot
is wait how do I get in to build
how do I wait a minute
here we go the top no go away okay
everybody shut up everybody shut up
everybody shut up we have prefabs
apparently okay everybody shut up
well can I make this bigger why can't I
make it bigger okay what's the cheapest
here we go linoleum dream perfect oh
that's exactly the garbage I would have
made anyway perfect all right by that I
believe that everybody should go through
the kitchen when they're on oh wait oh
no how do I rotate I forget out a rotate
all right front door here we go BAM got
it okay that's the front door all right
so the front door leads right into the
kitchen as we all knew it would now
we're gonna get all all custom custom
Westham here where the walls
how have I forgotten to play this game
already how there we go okay lamp
let's get those walls down how do I get
the walls down there we go got it okay
got it
thank you thank you me I thought of that
that is because I am a genius okay so
this how do I delete a wall segment oh
no opposite oh shoot I'm spending money
oh no wait hang on hold on a second how
do i how do I delete wall oh no control
ship
Oh control who's control okay control
got it perfect I knew that I knew that
so this will be the [ __ ] room and
then we got to make a lot of this is
gonna be the baby area why is that like
that okay here's the baby area a small
divide here it's gonna be a small
privacy screen and that's it that's it
okay so this this be the the the [ __ ]
room where the business is gonna happen
oh wait we got to put the baby's out on
the deck I forgot about that
wait we can make a basement oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] Oh
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] baby basement oh [ __ ]
okay here we go now we're now we're
getting into this now now we've got this
okay here we go furniture all right okay
so the babies are gonna go into a
basement hence the term babes meant for
babies and then they're all gonna have
their own pooping Thrones here we go
pooping Thrones this one get so special
and pooping Thrones and then they get to
sit oh yeah okay they get to sit and
look at their bed don't peekaboo where
mom and dad are [ __ ] alright so we're
gonna have a no peekaboo privacy screen
it's gonna be great no peekaboo
don't peekaboo unless you want to be
mentally scarred BAM all right so that's
the brilliant we're gonna get a nice
mirror for them to stare at themselves
right there yeah that's that's pretty
good that's that's pretty good and then
we need some kind of way to get to the
basement I suppose if I really think
about it I guess I guess I got a hmm I
guess how do i stair case I suppose
would be the answer to this question
stairs no those are outside stairs
where's my inside stairs
how y'all doing I'm up here now oh
there's 30 stairs same stairs
samesies stairs he wears these boom okay
it's just a hole in the ground so you
better watch my divider know my privacy
device now they're never gonna have any
privacy oh my god all right yeah
oh [ __ ] um wait no hang on this is much
smarter okay now it's still a hole in
the ground
well we can have divider don't look no
no peeping no no be written so over here
is gonna be the living room where we
live except we don't have any life so
I'm just gonna
to put a must be loveseat yeah cuz it
has to be loved to put up with this
[ __ ] okay and then this is call I
call this the The Listening
loveseat so you can hear her you can
hear the raucous sounds coming from here
and just in case you wanted to you know
just in case you wanted to catch a catch
a catch a catch a whiff whiff is the
wrong word but just in case I'm gonna
angle this so you can just so you can
just barely see what's going on so if
you're sitting here you can kinda just
barely see the back just a peep just so
just a little peep wait no yeah we got
it like this yeah I got this alright
it's like it's like Indiana Jones when
you're trying to get the light going but
you can still see the back enough
foreplay time to get down to business
let's live this life alright you guys
get in that bed alright right off the
bat there try for baby with Brunhilde I
didn't think it'd be that easy here we
go
let me see how this is gonna go down
[Laughter]
okay alright let's not watch my goodness
oh my goodness gracious
Oh wowee wow wow wow anyway this is not
what this is about
there's not it's not about it's not
about it's not about this isn't
perverted this isn't this isn't sexual
in any way this isn't about sexuality
none of that to do work or you try again
you go go for it alright speed it up
this time we don't have
we have time to wait around I don't know
if that worked did you did it work
welcome to the neighbor welcome to the
neighborhood and you don't want it you
don't want to be friendly hey come on in
come on in come on in man come on in hey
how you doing what's your name how you
doing
don't mind that I'm an alien raised
vampires lifestyle oh why did you just
vomit why cuz you're pregnant
oh hi neighbors hi Heidi hi-ho you're
more than yeah I thought there would be
of you oh there's no bathroom that's
okay
all right we'll worry about that later
let's speed up through this okay we need
jobs cuz we don't have a lot of time
left again we have like no oh oh they're
so in love all right we find that we
probably do let's uh let's let's build
let's build a bathroom let's put this
right let's I'll call this the danger
shower cuz right by the entrance is
right by the staircase so there's a very
very very extreme chance of slipping and
tumbling down the stairs we also need
some lights it's real dark in here Oh
spooky boo boo you could die in the
shower oh and then we need some sweet
kinky kinko nothing says romance like a
rack of protein powder oh my god I've
never seen something that would possibly
like entice some sims more to make
sweets passionate lava just just in case
you need to refuel mid-coitus
and how about a here's a rock there we
go that's good how was that expensive
Ock god damn it open-air natural
[Laughter]
we're good we're good to go we're good
to go you already have a baby
probably anyway but try again just where
did my well we're what wait a minute
where's my wall oh wait the walls are
down so okay nevermind we're fine
continue continue be inspired by the
display all right are you are you
program and got a good whoohoo does that
mean are you for Gannon aunt okay
whatever
alright so these guys need jobs because
if we don't have a job we ain't gonna be
able to do jack doodlee travel wait what
is this by a vet clinic she loves cats
she loves cats
wait why byah byah vet clinic was pink
what we're doing where do i Magnolia
what huh
well we can make a vet clinic on this
horrible plot of land we it's Virginia's
we can make a vet clinic all the cats so
many cats
we'll make our own genius we don't even
need money we can make money we can make
money well you make all our babies they
could work at the clinic yes all of it
all of it send all of it confirm yes
okay this is so genius oh my god am gene
well oh I just lost what I was doing
okay I'm a goddamn genius here we go
okay we don't need any of that we just
need okay one bucks there okay that's
good enough so we need certain things we
need an exam table bandage medicine
crafty dink I don't know what that is
step right up checking podium dr. budge
six and dr. budget oh hell yeah
Oh dr. budget ooh baby doctor budget oh
my oh me oh my
here we go the seeing less cuz we want
it to be very welcoming we want people
to feel welcome in here all right we
need a vet podium this one check-in
podium hey hey hey look hey look you
ain't going to have no regrets today is
you check in today you check out
tomorrow your pet will not you uh if you
know what I mean okay waste disposal
trashcan trashcan trashcan tray trash
can is it like a little like a trash can
we I guess
excitement is in the air can you tell by
the exclamation point oh yeah we yeah
this definitely doesn't look like a
crack den that's been graffiti'd all
over it paw and wellness just so people
know this is this legit we ain't no
crack den we as a vet we'll fix your pet
real good say I'm gonna go down here so
you can see this list I need a waste
disposal I'm assuming this sister trash
can right a barrel okay perfect got it
remember to dump your trash on the way
out yeah I knew it I knew that was what
was missing I knew it I knew it we could
have a surgery station we could have a
medicine crafting table but that Jones
free spensive but you know maybe we'd
like some medicine oh wait maybe this is
like oh maybe it's an automated check-in
so like I don't have to do anything for
the check and that sounds good okay then
we'll put this right here
oh hell yeah surgery station I don't
know what that means I don't even know
what surgery is I thought this was a vet
okay we'll put this here no that wasn't
even necessary a vendo machine oh that
sounds like dangerous yeah okay all
right I want I want to make the most
money pause oh and it provides light oh
you oh my god we can actually see what's
going on on the table all right cool Oh
perfect look at this oh yes it's
beautiful oh my god what a business what
a business and can we make a pissin bush
just so everybody has an option open air
natural toilet Oh perfect
you know like animals do perfect got it
okay all right we're good let's do this
live in it live it love it you own this
business currently [ __ ] open open
baby hell yeah all right you practice
singing shout for
you do that I don't see what that's all
about
oh my god brynhilda you're happy how in
the world are you okay alright well then
you want to be you want do customer
hello would you like a customer Oh what
would you like to be custom hello I'm
going to friendly introduce never mind
there guess the excuse me ma'am she gone
she just disappeared sir sorry sir sir
sir
hello stop going in the bush Brunhilde
you have customers Brunell de ok oh oh
Papo Papo the friendliest introduction
we will treat you
we will treat you so nicely yes new
customer new customer new customer
alright great patient hello hi how are
you welcome to my vet Oh blue means the
world to me
that's a great name and she hasn't been
feeling awful lately whatever you can do
to help will be greatly appreciated oh
of course blue love the best-ever
treatment here you son of a [ __ ] oh
look how great this table is oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you know you'd think that I
would need some kind of training for
this maybe some kind of like inner
knowledge of how a dog even functions
I'm a cat lover not really a dog lover
anyway um I guess I'll calm you down
never mind
exam check chart let's see what's on
your chart here boom is my finger smells
awfully weird okay alright let's take
your temperature shove a thermo right up
your bow to key oh that's not a thermo
and yeah I don't even know if you have
abotu key
all right skin fur low temperature I see
fur some kind of frost dog listen to
heart
yep that's a thumper oh shut up
I'm examining your dog can you shut up
I'm pregnant you shut up ice box fever
oh all right treatment antiviral payload
shove it right up the tuchus oh Sh Azal
posaga indeed very uncomfortable but
that's okay whatever you know that'll be
money can you give me money
can you get me some money can you get
why are you standing behind me can you
get them you want the money can I scare
you or your bull and wait hang on the
wait let me give you a goodbye scare we
get one free with each customer oh you
liked it all see it's not so bad alright
it is please go away I have to open up
have to open there go up in a vending
machine can you please get there get out
of my face all right let's say we're
gonna close all right close
Wow well done 125 bucks even better I
hate that all right let's go home how do
we go home go home go go home
go okay we're going on but we're getting
we're getting sidetracked here because
we don't have a lot of time I thought
that was gonna be more interesting than
it was turned out to be a big-ass waste
of time no one gives a [ __ ] about those
animals except for Brunhilde and you
know they'll be fine no matter what all
right how do we accelerate this baby or
deal
well we're broke okay all right nope oh
you need a job okay what did he want to
be I literally don't care what he wanted
to be but what did he want to be a straw
that would be so fitting that would be
so fitting for this alien no well we're
not gonna do that a critic hell yeah oh
hell yeah oh so you can get your
opinions on everybody the judged you so
harshly for your looks
okay hell yeah okay he starts Monday
hugging what did you just do
whoa brain what did you just do to
Brunhilde what did you just do you
zapped her with mind rays okay I have no
idea what happened there but that
doesn't make any sense at all all right
when how long does it take to pump out a
baby do you guys know how long it takes
to pump out a baby she's not bright how
is she not pregnant she threw up that
that means you're pregnant all right
okay all right hang on all right she's
not pregnant
oh we're gonna disc what's a disco nap
oh I don't care go to the bathroom if
you really have two in the bush where
did you go I'm sorry I you know I should
have I should have you know shouldn't
have questioned that oh well we didn't
even need a bathroom we got a bathroom
right across the street what the hell am
i doing all right all right you
dillweeds you dick holes get ready to
get a whole lot of baby going cuz
okay now you're back Oh would you like
to do oh go to work I guess
no butt babies you babies though okay
try for a baby before you go to work
quick real quick go for it go go go go
go go go go go performed poorly it
doesn't matter you were in a hurry you
gotta go to work okay so how long does
it take to make babies did you did
anyone say how long nine months in the
game damn it in get three days okay we
just gotta go three date how are you not
full of baby okay alright we're gonna
build a toilet oh no that that's a
terrible toilet there's a horrible
toilet that is this is the worst toilet
ever we have no money but that that is
just a that's that's just there's so
many things wrong with that toilet that
I can't even begin to start we need
money we have no money we gotta weigh it
for money when money comes then then we
buy toilet then we take pregnancy test
then we have baby yes okay well I don't
know where you're going you're gonna
make snow angels oh boy she's so happy
baby yeah okay so she's totally got a
baby inside of her grates anyway okay Oh
know what a free spirit okay where's can
I focus on you oh he's back okay he's
unhappy but that's okay cuz there I've
got babies hip bump give pep talk share
pig nose there we go we're gonna share
some big news you better get out of
there share the bond potato through the
litter low 30
what kind of a response was that what
what what didn't the fresh hell response
was that ha ha ha ha ha
listen it doesn't matter what you want
what you don't want it doesn't matter
do we have money we got some money can
we buy a toilet we can buy a litter box
can you [ __ ] in the litter box put in
inventory what that doesn't do anything
for us all right so they're gonna make
they're gonna there's a cheaper toilet
well I'm sorry I spent all my money on
the cat litter box you can't blame me I
thought it would be a cheap alternative
to do a toilet
turns out of what are you napping in
there all right whatever they're gonna
like the babies grow and hopefully it
gets here soon I don't know how much
time we have left until we grow up
who the hell is Nancy all right whatever
you guys do whatever you're doing we're
how do we how do we tell how old we're
getting because we gotta be getting old
where's lifeline how do you do lifeline
yes the bush is leaking don't mind the
bush there it is
ten days Oh No Oh can you just go do
let's go to a light light fire Fester
okay all right
what a nice that's such a nice invite
well thank you we don't have a door of
course we don't have a door why would we
have a door doors are expensive we can't
even afford a toilet why would we have a
door
stupid dumb all right why are we here
and why do I care maybe we should
disguise ourselves that might be smart
mope oh you're just do hideously ugly oh
there we there we go
where do we light off some fire warrior
or where did everybody go oh oh you're
all glowing all right join the
pranksters join the pranksters together
join the pranksters I don't know what
that even means
what are these teams doing these goddamn
teens
whereas the fireworks
I was promised explode ease oh I got
some goddamn far worse before mischief
interactions can I do it now can I
perform a mischief interaction can I
miss your eyes you can I miss your visor
this toilet did I miss your visor this
tiki bar
oh try to gather let's get high as [ __ ]
bro with a hookah I don't know what I'm
doing there's so many [ __ ] there's so
much [ __ ] added to the Sims that I just
have no idea what to do yes suck down
that hookah oh it's a bubble you are
wasting the precious 10 days you have
left on this earth with goddamn bubbles
is that what you're doing can you hurry
the hell up with whatever you're doing
and get home to your pregnant wife
I just [ __ ] I'm out here for words
go home disband group
we're Dunn's Oh screw that you you stay
here whatever I'm going I'm how do I
focus on you how do i I don't how do i
how do I focus I want I just want to I
just want to see you
how do I go back how do I go back home
right-click on your sim to focus him um
right-clicking it ain't do nothing to me
light fireworks I can't learn a goddamn
fire cancel this event get the [ __ ] out
out eat get go home go home you hookah
smoking lazy piece of [ __ ]
just go home did you [ __ ] yourself ah
just go home go home run run you're
gonna [ __ ] your pants you're gonna [ __ ]
your alien pants alright are you doing
oh he [ __ ] himself right outside the
toilet what a piece of [ __ ] okay how
long six hours cool this is chaotic good
no this is this is trying to preserve
life these people are supposed to pump
out baby after baby and it's it's it's
it's like they are wasting their
precious - why are you awake
just sitting there whoa don't look at me
whoa [ __ ] just go to sleep sleep just
gonna sleep okay all right do you need a
job - we should probably get we should
probably get Brunhilde a job as well
because you know the vet didn't work out
but that was six thousand dollars down
the drain so you know um social media go
for it baby you go for that you go for
that [ __ ] don't you need to go to work
in time for work didn't you go to work
oh do you start tomorrow that's fine all
right whatever they're gonna be working
isn't she a vet no she's not a vet she
owns a vet it's totally different top we
can buy a toilet this is what separates
the boys from the men we cannot afford a
toilet we okay tomorrow tomorrow's a new
day we will get it we will get a toilet
tomorrow we will get a toilet tomorrow
and we will not worry about the fact
that we do not have a toilet today we
got a bush whoo no no no
no-no-no
this is against God so it's unholy oh no
the next baby's gonna be a bush baby
just so you all know that oh the next
baby's gonna be a bush baby no don't
worry I don't think anyone knew oh my
god you disgusting disgusting disgusting
horrible horrible horrible horrible I
would say humans but one of you is not a
human Santa and one of you is barely
human so multi-purpose Boosh for pooping
napping in oh what a good boost that was
the best fifty-fifty samolians we've
ever spent here can you believe how
happy these two are can you believe that
some people in the world work or live in
worse conditions than what you're saying
I'm gonna clean that Bush oh all about
were you about to throw up man you are
very very very unattractive from the
side profile I just wish I didn't have
to see this well just go to bed at 6:30
uh time for sleep let's go to sleep
time for bed okay never mind then
apparently it's not time for bed oh my
god oh she just she just shat all over
the floor there's a perfectly good Bush
she just shat all over the floor back to
dreams stuff yeah whatever you're very
embarrassed no one knew the only other
person was sleeping can I please see
this can I please see this can i okay I
can't third trimester in eight hours
okay so this baby's gonna be here soon
did you just puke in that Bush did you
just pick in that Bush will we deliver
the baby in the bush too if we can you
bet your sweet ass we are you uh you
pregnant too or you just okay whoa whoa
whoa what the [ __ ] why the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] was that the [ __ ] was that the
[ __ ] hell happened what the [ __ ]
happened why are you in our home
what this is showing her as asleep this
says she's asleep that why are you in
our home
wait can you keep trying to cheer up
there's no are you just part of this
family now okay all right there's no
option to get her to leave
so you're here and V Gupta wait a minute
wait she doesn't have a reflection it's
a vampire
she's got no reflection she's got no
reflection she's a vampire how do we get
you to get out of here
well uncomfortable okay horrible shower
you know what whatever we're just gonna
go to sleep and if you leave that's
great just thank you for getting off the
bed okay that was weird
all right we're just not gonna talk
about that no one mentioned that nothing
happened whoa father winter please daddy
winter come give us presents
please come on daddy cloth daddy winter
please daddy
oh god daddy winter please come down my
chimney oh I'm so sorry for the way that
I am I'm sorry look listen listen I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm not sorry at all
we're just crying it we crying
underneath were you crying I don't know
what we're doing here I've forgotten the
point of life give birth in room all
right come on let's see it chop chop
come on we got a schedule
keep let's go hey man now any minute now
you're gonna pop like a water balloon
good thing we got a baby basement all
set up and ready to go
here we go a man now this baby's gonna
boom zhuang zoom boo right out of there
come on come on
we're never gonna see this baby we're
never gonna see this baby whoa whoa whoa
whoa what daddy daddy winter Clement
Frost
just right on the ground there eh okay
all right well you just gonna go be here
are you a vampire too
I can't get his reflection from here
okay he's not a vampire we got that for
sure can I help you sir
can I help you sir another glass of
water
oh another glass for water he's got to
rehydrate for all his festive needs who
are you Oh drink water and get a door no
oh oh well um not the clothes did you
just pick up the class of the thank you
thank you so much I appreciate it
oh you [ __ ] ass
[Music]
and you're done oh okay all right
please mr. frost don't steal mo Poe's
wife I don't know where this is leading
or how this got to this situation at all
or in any way and you're just making
garlic bread
okay all right well I think this this
lifestyle is just gone awry in many ways
and I feel oh wow um let's go see where
time leads us Oh [ __ ] if you die from
this fire before you get to witness the
miracle birth of your wife and your
first baby okay good all right that's
time for Santa Claus to peace out there
oh boy [ __ ] I'm out I'm off soon
I've spent a few hours here drank your
water and I'm off that why is my mailbox
over there check for Winterfest gifts I
got three candles okay can you have this
baby please just to have the baby
after the baby we need to fill up the
cribs we spread all our money out cribs
we have money how did we get money
how do we get money okay well uh we'll
buy a toilet no you know what what's not
oh boy I have no idea whoa Brunhilde is
bursting
she's bursting to have baby have baby
Oh your mich Oh
everybody's sad a little grundle oh my
god alright time for baby number two oh
it's gonna be a baby
it's Bush baby oh Jesus oh my god oh
[Music]
actually a good Bush baby oh my god
no no one's ah no one wanted to see
everyone knew but you know no one wanted
to see you try again come on you gotta
get in there oh they're going for the
baby all right they're here the baby
doesn't get fed alright here we go
back in the bush okay just in case you
know just to really solidify it
alright let's buy a turlet alright okay
the ambassador emphasis on acid or you
need to take a pregnancy to $15 $15 oh
can you get from home already we need to
know if we gonna need to go in the bush
again honey we gotta go in the bush
again turned up negative I know I tried
real hard last time but you know how
these things is they think oh it worked
nevermind we don't got another one
Oh baby Yahoo oh boy a baby factory
that's what we are
little boy okay and we're gonna die very
soon very soon
brynhilda yurt why are you 12 days from
a job
are you ageless because you're a mother
is that what it is why are you saying it
taking so long to be moko is good and
older by the second why have you not
aged at all since that her pregnant
cannot age up so if she's always
pregnant oh well I didn't ever at what
does everyone know about this secret if
you're pregnant you can't get all them
oh my god I gotta get pregnant oh okay
this is it
Wow you want to woo hoo in a Boosh
that's an aspiration of yours yeah okay
one less woo no can't do it she's asleep
can do it hey wake up wake up hey wake
up we gotta woohoo we gotta do this we
have to we have to alright here we go
there's my dream now oh what a
supportive marriage man one thing you
gotta say they are truly in love it
takes love to be willing to go through
all that
especially for a horrible hideous alien
and grundel grundles bingo you are oh my
god you are being horribly abused okay
one of you should probably change the
baby art we're just gonna ignore the
okay anyway that's I think I think it's
okay go away now
[Music]